we are told
in this article published on july 28
2020
um here's zach if you want to show uh
this article
briefly uh jk rowling and the white
supremacist history of biological sex
this article um tells us it's going to
be speaking too
uh so did you did you show it and i've
taken it down now zach
okay good um a quotation this is so
a friend of uh an online friend of mine
a person who is trans
uh forwarded this to me and said would
you please please please please
take uh address this in your next live
stream
uh and so and so we are gonna do it just
very briefly you haven't read the piece
but you can imagine what's in there
um so i'm gonna i'm gonna have a couple
of quotes here certainly has a
tantalizing title oh
so tantalizing jk rowling in the white
supremacist history of biological sex
um so one quotation from it is as many
people are engaging in conversations
about how white supremacy has shaped so
many of our political and social
institutions there is no better time
than the present
to talk about how biological sex and
sexual difference were created
or created over time to protect promote
and police the boundaries of whiteness
that is a quotation created biological
sex was created over time to protect
promote and police the boundaries of
whiteness
um boy this article is
crackbot mess it's a crackpot mess of
misunderstandings about evolutionary
theory again
always right always and illogical
conflations
i'm gonna let's deal with a couple of
them it conflates the veracity of an
idea
with the wrong thing of people who've
stood near that idea it's a classic bait
and switch move right um
and it it happens all the time in
evolution you know people misunderstand
or want to appropriate a
bad understanding of evolutionary
thinking and claim it as their own
and conclude stupid illogical racist
sexist whatever it is conclusions
and then people who want therefore to
believe that anything evolutionary is
racist sexist whatever
say aha those people over there they
said that they're doing what you're
doing
to which we could say but they're not
they're wrong they're confused they're
bad like that's not what they're doing
um that the fact that stupid people or
wrong-minded people stand next to ideas
doesn't
make those adjacent ideas wrong like
this just seems so obvious
and yet we deal with this all the time
um okay so here's a quote from the
article
darwin and his followers argued that all
human peoples were related but it was
said that different races were on
different scales or stages
all human beings were now to be viewed
and judged as being on a racialized
continuum where intelligence beauty
morality fecundity and physical ability
increased
as one moved up evolutionary stages of
course the white europeans who
formulated these theories considered
themselves the most advanced
so that's some 19th century [ __ ]
misunderstanding of what darwin said and
it's not what evolutionary biology is
it's not how evolution works it's not
about stages it's not about hierarchies
well i want to push back just slightly
there is a hierarchy
in paleontology that describes a
move from basically familial units
up through civilization you know so um
before you get to
a tribal system you get to uh uh in
anthropology you mean then yeah
paleoanthropology oh okay okay um
that you have a uh a head man system
anyway there is a progression there's
hierarchy within populations for sure
right and when this is yes
this was understood in darwin's time
by darwin in other words there is some
stuff that you have to read in the
context of
the uh the level of understanding that
existed
uh when darwin was writing on the other
hand there was also
a awareness that is now caricatured out
of existence
that even to the extent that there was
some sort of understanding that
uh hunter-gatherers were in some way
primitive
there was no sense that that inherently
meant
that they weren't headed towards
civilization and finding themselves in a
different stage so
anyway i don't want to dwell uh in the
19th century
right now in order to sort it out that's
the big flaw here right
yeah but anyway the point is look you
know
you could do a sober analysis here of
what they had right and what they had
wrong and what
persists and what doesn't and and all of
that
or you can go verification we're not
arguing
that uh all people are equivalent
or all cultures are equivalent or as
good at doing everything that other
cultures are doing nope that's not true
not true at all and there are those who
would argue that and therefore
our claim that some some people in some
cultures are better
at doing some things than other people
in other cultures are doing would claim
that that in itself was the same thing
as this
racist garbage when it's not right
um and in fact okay so another
just one other thing this article does
um
it discusses actually discusses an idea
again from 19th century race garbage
that i hadn't even heard before i
thought i'd heard all the stupid things
that emerged from supposedly you know
evolutionary thinking but apparently um
high degrees of sexual dimorphism in
humans
was um supposed to be an indicator of a
more evolved race
which is so and the person writing the
article doesn't know what they're doing
they're completely clueless
and so they actually seem to claim the
opposite but you go look at the link and
it's like oh okay so
you know these these people in the 19th
century
who were trying to use science to
justify their racist conclusions came up
with this
they found that um you know european
they they found evidence that europeans
had more sexual dymorphism than men and
women are more different than europeans
than other races uh they were talking
about
um uh indicators just all
across the board it seems not just not
just height i don't think
um but it's
again the fact that there have been
confused racists who spin their
fantasies in the language of science
does not make the science racist right
the fact that you have an idea that is
taken
and used to some end that is not okay
does not make the idea itself not okay
those aren't the same thing so
again the whole article is this actually
what i've written here is it's a
verificationist mess it is it is that
it's a verificationist mess of motivated
reasoning and sloppy thinking
but it's also true so i
i kind of threw up my hands like this
this is some let's see what is he the
author of this article
is a phd candidate in political science
and also a student in feminist studies
um so he can't get it right that's
higher ed for you at the moment um
that's that's terrible and we've talked
about that a lot um
but i wanted to actually just use this
as a segway to quickly say something
about you know
again that even scientists are hiding
behind this kind of
of logic now and some of them actually
seem to believe it so a friend of a
friend a biologist friend recently
shared his
biologist friend's claim uh that
everything is a social construct
and this this guy this former i think
friend of a friend
literally uses the fact that there is no
single definition of species
that works for all species to then claim
that both math and sex are social
constructs
so just i'm going to repeat that because
there is no single definition of species
that works for all species
the unspoken connector here is all
biological constructs
categories are the same therefore math
is a social construct and sexist is such
a construct and gender is a social
construct and everything's a social
construct
so i i responded to my friend who shared
this this guy's a biologist
are you kidding me like to conflate the
lack of universal species concept
with the lack of any formal you know
firmly definable categories in the world
is to abandon the idea of an objective
universe
like he this guy doesn't get to call
himself a scientist
actually like i i wish sometimes i wish
i could be king for the day
and take all of these phds away from
people
because this is such a serious
failure of of logic and if you are
actually claiming to be a biologist who
thinks who has looked at
all at diversity of species and decided
that
the lack of a universal species concept
is mappable onto there is no
sex that's ridiculous you and i used to
face students
you used to meet students who came from
totally crap k-12 educations
who somehow have been totally totally
confused by creationist households
and within weeks of meeting these 18
year olds we would disabuse some of this
nonsense
and now we have phds in the sciences who
are arguing this
it's insane i don't i don't think this
guy would recognize a phylogeny if it
hit him upside the head
and i'd kind of like to see it do it
yeah
watch one of these trees falling exactly
so at some level
it's such witlessness and cowardice it's
insane if you think
that sex is a social construct you're
doing it wrong
same goes for math
[Laughter]
yeah good good good good i like that
that was good so that was good yes
um are you are you where you wanted to
go with this sure i mean i could go off
for a long time well i just know what
i'm gonna do i'm good
i want to point out that actually all
three of the characteristics that we've
been playing with
yes sit here you've got the
verificationism you're going to go
through
science and you're going to find
something like uh species
ambiguity which is real and assume that
that means ambiguity is the same for
every other category
that's verificationism you have
autoimmunity
where we are attacking the ability to
make sense right if you attack science
by basically taking any conclusion that
it would render and putting it in the
same category as something problematic
like species
then uh you are basically making it
impossible to establish anything
um and then there's psychosis right this
uh yeah well this if you think about
what it is like if you've ever
encountered a psychotic right
there is a belief
of a malevolent force that is attempting
to manipulate and endanger and there is
license
you can categorize it's all cops right
it's the cops right
they are the bad thing and in this case
right there is a you know do you know
what uh
sex is sex is a weapon of
white supremacy right that doesn't sound
paranoid as [ __ ] to you because it does
to me right that sounds like
the government is sending me messages
through the fillings in my teeth
you know and exactly right it's that
level of nonsense it was the claim that
it is
uh created the concepts of biological
sex and social difference were created
over time to protect promote and police
the boundaries of witness
right like 500 million years ago guys
well let's put it this way
you can even just test that
scientifically right you could just
simply go
to hunter-gatherers non-white people
and test the question of whether or not
they believe you don't even have to ask
them what they believe
you can just simply look at pairings
right
who pairs off with whom right they know
that sex exists whether they use the
same terminology for it
that we do or not and you can establish
science when it's homosexual parents
which does happen
um in every culture known do they make
babies
no they don't no sex was not created
for white supremacy where do they expect
to right they know that those pairings
don't
produce babies so the point is you could
test it scientifically uh what's the
next move
that scientific concept you are using to
establish that this is not
a tool of white supremacy is itself
white supremacy so of course it would
conclude
that right so the point is okay right
exactly it's a hermetically sealed
psychotic box
into which they want us all to go to go
right what could possibly go wrong what
could possibly go wrong